[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
-So thank you all for coming.
This is a good turnout.
And I hope you've been able to
join us for some of the earlier
parts of our DNA series.
And know that there's
some more to come still.
It's my pleasure to
introduce Dan Barouch tonight
for his talk-- as you can
see-- prospects for a vaccine
and cure for HIV.
Dan is a professor of medicine
at Harvard Medical School,
and-- as you can see--
director for the Center
for Virology and Vaccine
Research at Beth Israel.
He is also part of the Reagan
Institute of Mass General, MIT,
and Harvard.
He's going to talk
tonight on how
molecular sciences revolutionize
the approach to vaccine
and drug development.
The goal of the lecture is
to describe the current state
of the HIV epidemic
and the prospects
for developing a vaccine
and a cure-- a real cure--
for this disease.
Dan's laboratory has explored
a series of novel vaccine
technologies, advancing in
particular series of novel
adenovirus-- I have
to read this because I
know none of this stuff.
I may be an epidemiologist,
but I do heart disease.
Novel adenovirus
vector-based HIV-1 candidates
from concept and design,
to preclinical testing,
to phase one clinical trials,
currently underway both
in the US in South Africa.
His laboratory is
part of the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation
Collaboration for AIDS Vaccine
Discovery, the NIH Center
for HIV and AIDS Vaccine
Immunology, and-- as you can
see here-- the Regan Institute.
So please join me in
welcoming Dan Barouch.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you very much, Janet.
It's a pleasure
to be here today.
Thanks for coming on
this beautiful afternoon.
What I'd like to try
to do is to give you
an overview of a
research topic that I've
spent a lot of thinking about
over the last 10 years really,
which is on how do we tackle
the HIV/AIDS pandemic in a most
definitive way,
which, as I'll argue,
is the development of a vaccine
and/or a cure for this disease.
We currently have
many drugs that
can control this
disease, but currently
no method that can
either reliably
vaccinate against this disease
or be a definitive cure.
Also, it's a pleasure to
be part of the DNA series.
And I think that
from my talk you'll
see how we use
molecular science, which
of course involves
recombinant DNA,
to both think about the
problem and attack the problem.
So I'd like to try to keep
this as informal as possible.
So feel free to interrupt,
raise your hand,
or just speak out
questions along the way.
I know there is time for
discussion at the end,
but I'm happy for this to be
a dialogue for the first half
of the session as well.
So don't be shy and
feel free to interrupt.
Also if you don't
understand something
or if you want to discuss
something further,
then feel free to ask
at any point in time.
I've tried to keep
the technical jargon
to a minimum in
this talk and I'll
try my best to explain some
actual scientific concept
of what we're trying to do and
the way we think about this
in as understandable language
for a non-specialist as
possible.
If I lose anyone,
then let me know.
And also hopefully things
will be brought back together
periodically.
OK.
So first, I think many
people will remember
in the 1980s-- and
even early 1990s--
how HIV was at the centerfold
of newspaper headlines on a very
frequent basis.
Over the last five,
10 years-- largely
due to the advent of therapies--
then HIV has, to some extent,
partially receded
from public view.
And to some extent that's
also one of the dangers,
that it's not imminently in
the public mindset as much
as it once was.
It doesn't mean the
problem is less severe,
it just means that it's not
in the headlines every day
the way, say, for example,
the Ebola epidemic
was in the headlines-- you
couldn't have missed it
if you were awake for any
portion of this past year.
But I think it's
important to keep
in mind the scope of the
HIV epidemic to start with.
In other words, how
much of a problem is it?
These are some data
graphics that we borrowed
from an article in
National Geographic that
looks at the estimates
of fatalities
for major epidemics
of infectious disease
throughout the world
throughout history.
So for example these
are different epidemics
that have occurred in
the world over time
with the size of the
red circle essentially
reflective of the
number of fatalities
of different infectious disease.
So you can see at the bottom
the SARS epidemic, which
was very much in the
headlines about 10 years ago--
or 2002 to 2003--
claimed almost 800 lives.
Clearly something of
substantial magnitude.
The Haiti cholera
epidemic starting in 2011
has claimed over 6,000 lives.
The Ebola epidemic-- these
numbers are a bit outdated.
I think the complete counts
for the Ebola epidemic,
the 2014-2015 Ebola
epidemic in West Africa
is about 11,000 people--
so, substantially larger
than the 8,000 here.
This was prepared
a few months ago.
But still about the
same size dot-- maybe
between this size and this size.
So a very substantial
epidemic that
clearly captured the world's
attention, huge resources,
and a massive global response.
The great plague of
London 100,000 people.
These cholera epidemics were
several hundred thousand
people.
The swine flu outbreak in 2009
claimed about 300,000 deaths.
But if we keep going up to even
the more significant epidemics
in history then you can
see that all of these
actually are relatively small.
So in terms of the scope,
say of the Ebola epidemic,
it was actually
fairly small compared
with some of the other
epidemics that you'll see.
For example, if
we keep going up--
and this is just to
show a few of these--
the plague around 1900 was
about 10 million deaths.
The Asian flu in the 1950s
was about two million deaths.
The 1918 flu claimed
almost 20 million lives.
And just for comparison,
the HIV/AIDS epidemic so far
has claimed 39 million lives.
So really a very
substantial epidemic
that takes its place in
history as one of the defining
infectious disease
epidemics of all time,
superseded only by the Black
Death in the Middle Ages,
which claimed an estimated 50
million lives and the plague
of Justinian during
the Roman Empire
that claimed roughly
100 million lines.
So that's where the HIV/AIDS
AIDS epidemic falls in terms
of historic proportions.
More discretely, the number
of adults and children
living with HIV is approximately
35 million currently.
And there's approximately
two million new infections
per year.
And these numbers over
the last couple years
have remained largely constant.
So the mortality
rates have starting
to drop, which is a good thing.
But the number of
people living with HIV
has actually continued
to increase over time.
But to some extent
that's good news--
that means that people are
actually living longer.
But that also means that
the total global burden
of the disease is growing
and not shrinking.
In addition, globally
HIV disproportionately
affects young women.
This is data from South
Africa in which you
can see that the greatest
burden of this disease
is in young women, essentially
as early as age 15 and going up
to the early 30s.
And you can see that throughout
Africa, really-- this
is data from South
Africa, but this
is the same in many
other regions in Africa--
that the burden of this disease
is much larger in young women
compared with young men.
And currently in South Africa
in early adulthood about 35%
of women are HIV positive.
These are some data in
a hyperendemic region
that so we do some
clinical research with.
And this is one of our sites
for our vaccine trials.
These are data from Salim
and Quarraisha Abdool Karim--
recent data-- showing really
still a stunning HIV prevalence
and incidence rate
in this community.
So this is a community
outside of Durban,
South Africa in which
over the last few years
the HIV prevalence
rate really has not
declined much at all,
despite the introduction
of antiretroviral
drugs to the region
and massive behavioral
and educational campaigns.
Then essentially
those do not seem
to impact the transmission
rate of HIV in this population.
By age 16 about 8% of women
are already HIV positive.
In this community by age
20 about 25% of these women
are HIV positive.
And by age 24 over 40% of
these women are HIV positive.
So that between the 18
to 35 year time frame
is about a 9% incidence
rate per person per year.
And this is with
the availability
of antiretroviral
drugs for prevention
as well as behavioral
interventions.
So clearly something
more needs to be done.
This is also a
clinical research site,
a site called CAPRISA,
that we were working with.
And it's a challenge doing
research in the developing
world, but this is actually
a very well established
clinical research
site that has made
some of the most seminal
advances for both HIV and TB.
And so this is a township.
And they're associated
with the Nelson Mandela
School of Medicine.
And this is one of our
sites for our vaccine
and therapeutic trials.
So that's globally.
Clearly the vast burden
of the disease is global.
And the largest
percentage of HIV cases
is in sub-Saharan Africa.
But how about the US?
It's still a major
problem in the US.
In the US there's about 50,000
new infections per year.
And about 2/3 of these-- 64%--
are in men who have sex with
men.
Also there's a certain level
of complacency in the US.
In young people
the incidence rates
are increasing, not decreasing,
particularly in individuals
13 to 24 years old-- there's
been a 15% increase in HIV
incidence rates.
And you can see that there's
a geographical maldistribution
of cases with the most HIV
cases in the US in the south
as well in the Northeast--
including here in Massachusetts
as well in Washington DC.
So Massachusetts, New York,
and Washington DC areas
as well as the South is
where there's the majority
of HIV cases in the US.
In fact some cities-- such as in
certain areas of downtown DC--
have such a high
HIV incidence rate
they would actually
qualify for US PEPFAR
if they were in Africa.
So people don't
realize that in the US
in certain regions
in certain cities
the incidence rates actually
are still very high.
Also, I think most people know
that the mortality for HIV very
thankfully plummeted in
the mid 1990s as a result
the introduction of combination
antiretroviral therapy, which
is, as we talked about, is
lifesaving but not curative.
However, from the late 1990s--
so for the last 10 or 15
years-- the mortality
rate in the US
has largely remained constant.
So despite continued
medical advances then,
we haven't made a lot of
headway in HIV therapy
in the US the last
10 or 15 years, which
is a surprise to many people.
And that's not entirely
due to the lack
of medical interventions.
It's due to many
societal, and social,
and economic issues
associated with this disease.
Another thing that is a
surprise to most people
is that the majority of
HIV-infected patients in the US
actually are not
adequately treated.
So these are recent data
from the CDC showing
that only about 3 in 10
people with HIV in the US
are actually receiving
suppressive antiretroviral
therapy.
This was actually a surprise
to me as an infectious disease
clinician.
So I wear two hats-- I'm
trained as an infectious disease
and internal medicine
trained physician, as well
as a basic scientist
as an immunologist.
And so for me, HIV
research is really
a merging of my clinical
interests and my basic research
interests.
But despite all my background,
I was actually very surprised
to see this, that in the US
about 15% of people with HIV
are not diagnosed.
Of course if you're not
diagnosed you can't be treated.
But only about
half of the people
who are diagnosed actually
are in a stable medical care
situation, which really speaks
to the socioeconomic side
of this disease.
And then of those,
a small percentage
are not prescribed ART and
a small percentage are not
adequately biosuppressed.
But when you multiply
all these things up--
it's called the
cascade of care--
the actual total number of
people who are fully suppressed
on antiretroviral
therapy, it's not 100%--
like some people think--
it's actually about 30%.
And of course the 70%
of people in the US
who are not adequately
treated are the ones
who have viral loads
that can continue
to transmit to other people.
And that's one of
the reasons why
we've made little progress
in HIV care in the US
in the last 10 years.
So how do we end
the HIV epidemic?
Clearly antiretroviral
therapy is the backbone,
and that's absolutely necessary.
But we also believe
that is not sufficient,
that antiretroviral
therapy alone is not
sufficient to cure disease.
In fact, if you look at
history, then therapeutics alone
are usually not
sufficient to eradicate
an infectious pathogen.
So what we need to do
is we need to find
a cure and we need
to find a way to
prevent the disease.
-I have a question.
-Yes
-Can you compare the geography
of America with Europe and Asia
with the prevalences?
-So in Western Europe and in
the industrialized countries
in Asia, it's
relatively similar.
I don't know the exact numbers,
because this was really
a US-based study.
But it's not felt
to be hugely better,
although there are more social
supports in other countries.
And there's more universal
health care in other countries.
There's still a substantial
cascade of care.
I don't know the exact numbers.
I don't know that the
studies have actually
been done to be quantitatively
precise about that.
But the concept of
a cascade of care,
that on each step on the
pathway to actually having
suppressed virus that you
lose a percentage of people,
still holds.
Of course in other areas
of Europe and Asia,
then it's vastly different.
So what I'm going to do for
the next five minutes or so is
I'm going to digress and tell
you a little bit about HIV
as a virus.
So if I lose a few of
you, then don't worry.
I'll tie things up
in a few minutes.
So this is a picture
of an actual virus.
This is a cell-- the
pink thing is a cell.
And these green
blobs are viruses
that are budding off the cell.
So this is a cartoon of what
an HIV virus looks like.
It involves nucleic
acid core-- an RNA core.
So I know we're in a DNA series,
but this is RNA, it's similar.
It goes through a
DNA intermediate,
so it still qualifies
for this lecture series.
[LAUGHTER]
It is an RNA virus.
There's proteins that
around the RNA that
make the viral
capsid-- essentially
it's almost the ball
that contains the RNA.
And then at the very
surface is a lipid
membrane-- it's sort of
a detergent membrane,
that sort of floppy surface.
And stuck in the membrane
are the coat proteins,
a single protein called HIV
envelope, also known as gp120.
So don't worry about the names.
Just remember that on
the surface of the virus
there's a single protein that's
called HIV envelope or gp120.
And that has to be the
target of antibodies.
So whether it's
antibodies induced
by the disease or antibodies
induced by a vaccine,
then that's the target.
If we look at the life cycle
of how does HIV actually infect
a cell, that is shown here.
This is the virus that I showed
you before, little smaller.
And this is, say,
one of your cells--
if the virus is
going to infect you.
It enters the cell by
attaching to a surface protein
on the cell called CD4.
You probably have heard
that in HIV infection
your CD4 counts go down.
What that actually means
is that the number of CD4 T
cells in your body declines.
This is a CD4 T cell.
And it's critical,
because CD4 is
the molecule on the cell that
allows the virus to go in.
So once the virus enters,
then the RNA genome
is reverse transcribed
into a DNA template.
So basically, a carbon copy--
almost a photocopy of the RNA--
is made as DNA.
This uses a viral enzyme
called reverse transcriptase.
And this is something unique
to this class of viruses.
So DNA is then
made from the RNA.
And the DNA goes into the
nucleus and integrates
into your host chromosomes.
That's a critical event
in the HIV's life cycle,
because that event
of integration
of the viral DNA
into your host DNA
is the reason why
we can't cure HIV.
So that's maybe one good
take-home lesson from this
lecture, is that that is the
single most important reason
why we cannot cure
HIV infection.
It's because the virus
integrates into your host
chromosomes and then a subset
of those cells, essentially
the virus goes to sleep.
If the virus is not actively
producing viral proteins,
it can't be targeted by drugs.
And therefore the cell
essentially lives on for years.
And if you stop therapy--
if you're HIV infected
and you stop
therapy-- then virus
starts to replicate
in those cells again
and the virus comes back.
So it has the potential
of repopulating
a whole other cycle
of viral replication.
Yes?
-I recently heard
a lot of our DNA--
the introns are retrotransposons
from other viruses, not
necessarily HIV, but
have been suppressed.
-That's true.
So what this gentleman
is referring to
is that in every
single person's cells
there are pieces
of retroviruses--
those viruses that are cousins
of HIV-- that presumably
viruses have lived on with
us for millions of years.
And those pieces of viruses
don't cause a problem,
because they're not intact,
they're not full viruses.
They can't actually
reactivate to make a virus.
So they're essentially
pieces of DNA
that are largely
almost irrelevant.
They're just sort
of sitting there.
I mean in your genome only a
small fraction of the genome
actually is genes that are
relevant for your cells
to live.
And so within the cells
a lot of the junk areas
contain sequences
that reflect portions
of genes that look like HIV.
And that's just a normal
part of being human.
Yes.
-I've got a question.
In theory, in our
wildest dreams,
could we use a technique--
a gene editing technique
like a CRISPR-Cas9
to excise the HIV?
-Yeah, absolutely.
So actually a gene therapy
is one of the strategies
for HIV cure strategies now.
And I can get to that
maybe towards the end
of the talk more.
But people can do that.
It turns out it's
probably easier
to target the co-receptors,
such as CCR5 disruptions, which
is the actual strategy
that people are using.
But absolutely that's
one of the strategies
that people are using.
So this integration
event is mediated
by a viral enzyme
called integrase--
it's not terribly creative.
But again, I'm emphasizing
it because this
is the molecular event
that is the reason why
we can't cure the disease.
Then the integrated DNA, as you
probably know from previous DNA
lectures, transcribes RNA.
And the RNA can either
translate viral proteins--
and the proteins
in the viral RNA
get packaged at the cell surface
and then new viruses bud off.
So one infected cell can
have many different outcomes.
It can either go to
sleep-- and essentially
the virus just stays
latent potentially
for months, maybe even years.
Or it can actively produce
virus, in which case
it can produce
hundreds, thousands,
or millions of virus particles.
So the reason why
I went over this
is because this is
critical for therapies.
So all of the HIV
therapeutic drugs
target these very unique
aspects of the viral life cycle.
So there are currently more
anti-HIV anti-viral drugs
than anti-viral drugs for all
other viruses put together,
just to show you the impact
and the pharmaceutical effort
to develop HIV
drugs, which has been
one of the biggest
pharmaceutical successes
of our generation.
So initially-- a large
number of HIV drugs
target this reverse
transcription step.
They're called reverse
transcriptase inhibitors--
AZT, you may have heard of,
is one of those type of drugs.
The drug class that really
transformed the AIDS epidemic
in the mid 1990s were called
protease inhibitors that
target this protease enzyme.
I didn't talk about
this much, but it's
an enzyme that cleaves
this initial protein
into the individual
structural proteins that make
a viral particle infectious.
And more recently
integrase inhibitors,
which target this step.
And so these three steps--
some fusion inhibitors
and other receptor antagonists.
But for the most part,
the vast majority
of HIV patients who are
prescribed antiretroviral drugs
are prescribed some combination
of reverse transcriptase
inhibitors, protease inhibitors,
and integrase inhibitors.
And this is the
backbone of HIV therapy.
So in an untreated
individual what
happens is that an untreated
individual is infected,
virus in the first few
weeks-- shown in red--
goes up sky high, and that
it's controlled partially
to a so-called viral set point.
The virus usually doesn't kill
the host in the first few weeks
and the host can't
clear the virus.
So they sort of end
up in a stalemate,
where the host is essentially
killing a very large number
of viral particles per day
and the virus continues
to replicate every day.
And this is an
analogy of a faucet
in a bathtub ongoing
but the drain also open.
So a lot of water is being
poured in but a lot of water
is being drained out
at the same time.
Eventually if the
individual is not treated,
then in more than 90% of
people after a period of eight
to 10 years develop
constitutional symptoms,
opportunistic infections,
and death due to the disease.
So there's a substantial
benefit to bringing
antiretroviral drugs to the
developing world, shown here.
And it's one of the most
lifesaving interventions
that the Western world has
done for the developing world
and is led by the US,
as I think people know.
In the absence of
antiretroviral therapy
there would have
been about two to 2
and 1/2 million deaths per year.
And now it's down
to about one to one
to 1 and 1/2 million
deaths per year.
So really a substantial
number of lives
saved by antiretroviral therapy.
But it's not perfect.
As we talked about, limitations
of antiretroviral therapy--
it doesn't cure the infection,
it doesn't eradicate virus.
There's problems of compliance,
toxicity, drug resistance.
There's still inadequate
access in developing countries.
Only about half the individuals
in the developing world
who need the drugs
are able to take them.
And these drugs can also
be used for prevention,
for preventing HIV.
But there's a lot of challenges
to actually implement
that on a societal level.
So let's talk for
a few minutes more
about HIV vaccines
in particular.
Is an HIV vaccine necessary?
Certainly history is
on the side of vaccines
to prevent or to rid the
world of viral epidemics.
And this is an opinion
piece by several leaders,
including Tony Fauci, who wrote
this editorial about a year ago
and said, "Ultimately, we
believe, the only guarantee
of a sustained end
of the AIDS pandemic
lives in a combination of
nonvaccine prevention methods
and the development
and deployment
of a safe and
effective vaccine."
So clearly we need a vaccine
to end the AIDS epidemic.
But until we have
one, then we need
to implement all
the other nonvaccine
prevention methods that we have.
So why is there no
AIDS vaccine today,
despite over 30 years of
concerted worldwide research
on the subject?
It's a good question.
I mean it's not due
to lack of trying.
It's actually one of the
large biomedical research
enterprises.
So far it has not
been successful.
So before trying to
answer this question,
how did Edward Jenner
develop a smallpox vaccine
200 years ago without the
benefit of our knowledge of DNA
and modern molecular
biology and immunology?
Clearly the development
of a smallpox vaccine
was predicated on several
aspects of the virus.
There was a clear clinical
correlative protection
for Variola virus,
which is smallpox.
It was limited
antigenic diversity,
which means that smallpox
is a virus that DNA
sequences of the virus from
one person to the next person
were pretty much the same.
So you're dealing with a
single virus as opposed
to many different
strains of a virus.
And broad immune
responses could be
induced by attenuated viruses.
So a classic method
in developing vaccine
is making a weakened
version of that
that doesn't cause the disease
but is sufficient to raise
immune responses that can then
target the real infection when
it arrives.
In contrast, the challenges
in the development
of a prophylactic
HIV vaccine are
unprecedented in the
history of vaccinology.
Unlike the smallpox
virus, for HIV
there is extensive viral
clade and sequence diversity.
In fact, the amount
of genetic diversity
of HIV within a single
infected individual
is greater than the diversity
of global influenza,
just for comparison.
So if you need a new
flu vaccine every year,
then how are you going to
make a vaccine against not
just the strains of virus in one
person, but HIV for the world?
The second thing is what
we talked about already,
that HIV integrates
into the host genome.
So it establishes
latent viral reservoirs.
Also, not a single person
has cleared HIV infection
through immune responses.
There's been one
person who probably
has been cured by a series of
bone marrow transplantations,
but there isn't a
single individual
that we know about
that's cleared HIV
from immune response.
So we don't know exactly what
immune responses to induce.
The virus can mutate rapidly
and evade both antibody and cell
or immune responses.
And antibody responses can be
induced to target that one host
protein that I mentioned
at the beginning,
but typically those
antibodies are not
broad-- they don't target
many different viruses.
So there's no method that exists
to induce broadly reactive
neutralizing antibodies.
And as we mentioned,
attenuated viruses
are often used for vaccines for
things like smallpox, measles,
mumps, rubella-- that
some of you may have had.
But for HIV, attenuated
viruses are too unsafe.
So currently there's
no safe way of making
an attenuated version of HIV.
In addition, there's no small
animal model of disease,
thus requiring the use of
more expensive and cumbersome
non-human primates for
preclinical vaccine testing.
And there would need to be
some level of animal testing
before the FDA would allow
clinical trials to be done.
And there's also--
a reality is there's
much less pharmaceutical
interest in developing vaccines
as there is, say, for
developing HIV drugs.
Ken Kelley and I were
talking about that just
before the start
of this lecture.
So there's many
different challenges--
I'll just highlight two of them.
So is a schema showing
the extensive global HIV
genetic diversity.
So here you can see in
different areas of the world
different pie charts.
And essentially the different
colors on the pie charts
reflect different strains
of HIV, called clades.
Don't worry about
the specifics, just
notice that there's
many different colors
all over the place in the world.
And that just highlights the
diversity of virus strains
worldwide.
The second problem is
the envelope protein.
I mentioned that
at the beginning
there's a single protein
called HIV envelope that's
on the surface of the
HIV envelope-- again,
not terribly creative name.
But this is the one
and only protein
that can be targeted by
antibodies to hopefully prevent
the disease.
So just to illustrate
the problems
of generating antibodies against
this protein is shown here.
This is a real structure--
so this is not fiction,
this is not a model, this
is the actual real structure
of the HIV envelope protein.
That was solved just
a year and a half ago.
You can see that these are
the different protein chains.
The green is the gp120
protein and the red
is the gp41 protein.
Imagine that the viral
membrane is here,
and this here is
the external world.
So basically antibodies
that you would
need to make by vaccination
to block this disease
would have to come in from
a direction such as here
or here and essentially bind
to some of the green protein
chains.
This is a space filling model in
which you see what the globular
protein actually looks like.
But the key thing
is that the virus
has devised a way
to almost become
invisible to the immune system.
And it does this by covering
almost its entire coat
with sugars, also
known as glycans.
By covering the protein
coat with sugars,
then it's much less
reactive to antibodies.
Because most people's
antibodies bind to proteins
and not sugars.
And so a model of what those
sugars look like is shown here.
So you can see the
sugars are shown in blue
and are probably
floppy like this.
And this is about the number
and dimension of sugars.
So you can see if
you're an antibody,
and you need to bind
to the green stuff
to actually
neutralize the virus,
and you're coming in here,
then the virus is going
to be almost invisible to you.
So this is another reason
why developing an HIV vaccine
is so difficult.
So how have we done as a field?
In 30 years there's only been
for HIV vaccines that have been
tested for clinical efficacy.
So think about that.
In any other field of
medicine-- cardiology,
oncology, even
HIV therapeutics--
at any point in
time there's tests
of dozens of different
concepts for activity
in human clinical trials.
But for HIV vaccine
development there's
only been four
concepts that have
been tested for clinical
efficacy in over 30 years.
So I would argue that
that is essentially
insufficient for the global
magnitude of the epidemic.
And it really is an
entirely another talk
that would last a whole
afternoon to really discuss
why this is the case.
But as you can
imagine, it's going
to be a combination of
scientific challenges,
funding/logistic issues,
and many things put together
is really a barrier for
developing more HIV vaccine
candidates.
I won't go through the
technical aspects of these four,
but let me just tell you that
three of these failed and one
was a partial success.
So that's not a
great track record
for 30 years of global
research on something.
But it does show some
hope that at least one
of these trials-- shown
here-- with different vaccine
and mutagen components did
show a 31% protective effect.
So it's too low to be
licensed-- so it's not
relevant to the populations.
But it is a proof of concept
that developing an HIV vaccine
is possible.
And so here is the actual
data from this clinical trial.
The number of HIV
infections is on the y-axis
and the time of the
study is on the x-axis.
The placebo group
is shown in red
and the vaccine group
is shown in green.
And you can see that early on
in the first year of the study
these curves separated,
indicative of a vaccine effect.
But then after time these
largely look parallel.
So the interpretation
is that the vaccine had
some early efficacy and
that it was lost quickly,
which is the parallel
lines after that.
But it did lead
to some insights.
A large statistical
immunologic analysis--
don't worry about the
actual numbers here--
but after this trial was done
people looked very closely
at what types of
immune responses
were associated with
a protective effect.
And not surprisingly,
it came down
to envelope-specific antibodies.
So if you made certain
types of antibodies
against particular regions of
the envelope protein-- regions
that were a bit more
exposed than others,
that weren't impeded
by all those blue dots
that I showed you in
the previous slide--
then you were able
to be protected.
So where do we go from here?
So there is a
signal of protection
with one candidate HIV vaccine.
This efficacy was marginal,
transient, insufficient
for licensure.
And so the emphasis now is
really a two-pronged approach
to develop improved vaccine
strategies-- either a mimic
of what was done before,
which involved a pox virus
vector with a gp120 protein.
A vector is an attenuated
or harmless virus,
such as an adenovirus
or a pox virus that
doesn't cause disease
itself but you
can stitch in through
recombinant DNA pieces of HIV
to make it into a vaccine.
Or to develop entirely
different vaccine platforms
that have various benefits.
So this is a study
that we published,
and I'll just mention in a
couple slides what we're doing.
We're using an adenovirus as
an initial vaccine strategy
followed by an envelope
protein to specifically boost
antibody responses.
And in a preclinical
study we've shown
that this vaccine, which
is here shown in blue,
gives about a 50% protection
compared with control
vaccines shown in black.
So this is the number
of challenges required
to achieve infection in this
[? animal ?] model and this
is the percentage of
uninfected individuals.
And these data were
published just recently.
So the vaccines that
we're taking forward
involve priming with
these viral vectors--
so a harmless or attenuated
virus that's unrelated to HIV,
in this case it's an
adenovirus, a virus that causes
the common cold-- with HIV
antigens stitched inside,
followed by a boost with
different viral vectors
combined with soluble proteins.
And we're currently finishing
phase IIA clinical trials
in the US, in East Africa,
South Africa, and Southeast Asia
to look at safety and dose
confirmation and regimen
selections.
And if things look good, then
in the next probably two years
we should be able to start
efficacy trials together
with our academic and
industrial partners.
But assuming that
things go well,
then this will actually
be only the fifth concept
tested in 30 years in the
history of the epidemic.
Yes?
-I don't know why we
don't license things which
have-- is it 31% efficacy,
if I understood correctly--
and that's the male circumcision
prevention efficacy, right.
The [INAUDIBLE] is also far
from 100%, it's in the 40%, 50%.
If it's cheap, maybe it's a
matter of cost effectiveness.
But if it's cheap,
why not use it?
-It's a very good point.
And so there's been extensive
modeling on how effective
does an HIV vaccine have to be
to be of public health utility.
And in general the
public health authorities
in various parts
of the world say
that they would endorse
use of an HIV vaccine
if it were about 50% effective.
And there's everything
from cost of goods
to incidence rates
and public health--
basically the cost of
a roll-out, et cetera.
The tipping point would be
a vaccine that's about 50%
effective.
Of course in the
developing world
it's a very different
calculus than, say,
in the developed world,
where you would probably
demand a much higher
efficacy of a vaccine.
But it's a very good point.
And mathematicians, and
public health authorities,
and governments argue
about that all the time.
This particular
vaccine could not
be licensed because it was
more of an academic experiment.
There wasn't actually a
pharmaceutical company
behind it.
So there was just
no logistic way
the vaccine could be
brought to market anyway.
And so there are practical
considerations as well in
addition to.
So even if that vaccine
were 100% effective,
the way it was tested it could
not actually be licensed.
Because it would have to be
transferred to a company who
was willing to take it on
and other non-scientific
issues as well.
So I'm going to close
in the last five minutes
or so just with some
thoughts about a HIV cure.
It's to some extent the final
frontier of therapeutics.
As long as we
capture HIV patients
in clinical care and the
country has the resources
to support it, then we can treat
most HIV patients very well,
to the point where their
virus is suppressed
and their life expectancy
almost approaches
an uninfected individual.
But they have to
be on therapy daily
for the rest of their life.
Because currently
there is no way
that we can cure this disease.
We can just hold it in check.
So why do current
drugs fail to cure HIV?
We talked about it already.
It's because HIV integrates
into the host genome.
HIV establishes a latent
reservoir and long-lived CD4
cells during acute infection.
Essentially, HIV integrates
into the host genome
and a certain number
of those cells
go to sleep-- that's
called a latent reservoir.
The viral reservoir
is not eliminated
by antiretroviral drugs
because drugs only target virus
that is actively replicating.
-Just a quick point.
So the HIV is unusual
in its dormant phase?
-Yes.
Most viruses do not integrate
and do not go into latency.
And that's one of the
cardinal features of HIV.
Yes?
-Why would the virus
stay asleep for so long?
So you suggested it
was like 9 years or so.
What is happening
in that period?
-So another unique
aspect of HIV compared
with many other viral
infections is that it actually
is an infection of the very
precise immune cells that
fight infection.
So it's an infection of
CD4 T cells primarily.
So human T cells have
certain properties.
They can be many
different states.
One state of human T cells is
called central memory cells.
And those cells by their
nature stay fairly quiet
in lymph nodes for years.
The purpose of those
cells is a good thing,
that if you
encounter a pathogen.
If you've had smallpox once
then you'll never get it again.
And that's because T
cells and antibody cells--
B cells-- retain
memory for a lifetime.
And that memory is retained
through central memory cells,
in other words, specific cells
that have particular antigen
receptors that are able to
recognize smallpox virus,
or other viruses,
or other bacteria.
And central memory
cells, they're
designed to live for years.
So the same cell can live in
your lymph nodes for years.
And that's a property of
the human immune system.
So HIV to some
extent hijacks that.
And the long-lived
property of those cells
is conferred upon the
virus, because the virus is
part of the cell now.
Because the viral
genome is integrated.
So whatever is the
natural history
that cell is the
history of the virus.
So if those cells have a
half life of five years,
then you can actually do the
mathematical calculations,
that it would take 60 to
80 years for those cells
to essentially die off.
And that assumes that those
cells are not self-renewing,
which they are.
So the translation is that
those cells persist forever,
for the lifetime
of an individual.
-But what brings it out
of that latency period?
-That's a very good question.
It's not completely known.
Certainly some stresses do that.
So at any point in
time a percentage
of the central memory
cells get activated.
And when a cell gets activated,
it starts producing the virus.
And it can set off
a chain reaction
of new virus replication.
But the precise
molecular details
of how a cell goes into
latency and come out of latency
is actually the cutting
edge of research.
So one strategy for a
cure is not a cure at all.
But if you could lock those
cells in permanent latency,
if you could prevent them
from becoming activated,
then you don't need drugs.
So one consideration
for a cure is--
what you would
think about a cure
is-- finding a way to actually
eliminate all those cells.
But a second approach
to a so-called "cure,"
or at least a
functional cure, would
be if you could somehow
lock them in latency
and prevent that reemergence.
So only one person
in the world we think
has actually been cured of HIV.
It was an HIV
patient with leukemia
who had not one but two
bone marrow transplants
from a donor.
And the donor was selected to
have specific mutations in one
of the receptors that
resists HIV infection.
Unfortunately, that's
not translatable.
The next six cases,
those patients all
died from complications of
the bone marrow transplant.
So it's certainly
not something that
can be done for HIV patients
unless they have acute leukemia
and need the bone marrow
transplant for treatment
of leukemia.
And even so, it's incredibly
rare and incredibly difficult
to do.
-Was it a different donor
for the other six cases?
-They were different donors,
but the same mutations.
So it's just that allogeneic
bone marrow transplantations
carry about a 25%
upfront mortality rate.
And then we think that
this particular person
was cured because he actually
had a very rough course
post-transplant and required
a lot of immunosuppression,
and therapy, and reinduction,
and a second bone marrow
transplant.
So basically
complete replacement
of essentially every single
immune cell by a donor.
Yes?
-Yeah.
Just to be clear,
those subsequent five
were being treated for
some other leukemia,
not just for HIV?
-Absolutely.
I mean no physician would
ever do a bone marrow
transplant just for HIV.
It just wouldn't be ethical.
But all those patients required
the bone marrow transplant
for treatment of leukemia,
and they happened to have HIV.
So of course other cure
strategies are being evaluated.
So this is a list of
strategies that people
are pursuing for HIV cure.
So it is thought
that the earlier
you start antiretroviral
drugs the better.
But early therapy is
probably not sufficient.
Animal studies and human
studies have shown that.
You may have heard
in the popular press
the story of the
Mississippi baby.
And starting therapy within
hours of infection at birth
appeared to cause a long-term
remission after therapy
was stopped in that baby.
But then after a period
of about two years,
then the virus came
resurging back, showing
that at least one cell was
still infected with HIV
and was sufficient to cause
a full-blown infection.
There's drugs being developed
that can activate those cells,
the latent reservoir cells.
People are also using vaccines.
I talked about vaccines to
prevent infection-- people also
are using vaccines to
boost immune responses
in HIV-infected
individuals, with the idea
that if you can increase a
person's own immune system
that their immune
system might be
able to either control or--
ideally-- eliminate the virus.
There's also various
immunomodulators
that try to increase the quality
of those immune responses.
We talked a bit
about gene therapy.
That would essentially either
potentially excise the HIV
from cells or
disrupt the receptors
needed to sustain an infection.
We talked about bone
marrow transplantation--
it's the one success in the
world in 60 million infections,
and is not something that
could ever be expanded.
And our own concept,
which we helped
develop over the last two
years, is could we actually use
the rare but definable broadly
neutralizing monoclonal
antibodies, could
those be developed
as drugs to help target HIV.
So I told you that
it's very difficult
to raise broadly neutralizing
antibodies by a vaccination.
But there are very
rare individuals
that develop these type
of antibodies naturally.
And those antibody
genes can be cloned out
and can be developed essentially
as a pharmaceutical drug.
So this is a schema of
an HIV envelope protein.
This is the viral membrane.
The virus is down here.
And this is the
external world out here.
So there are a small number
of neutralizing antibodies
that have been cloned out
of HIV-infected people that
are very, very good and can
neutralize the vast majority
of viruses very effectively.
Now these are not
raised by vaccination.
Is are very rare B cells
in very rare individuals,
essentially pulling
needles out of haystacks.
So I just don't want people to
be confused by vaccination-- so
far it's impossible to
raise this type of antibody.
But by molecular techniques one
can pull occasional anybodies
out of people.
And the best
antibodies potentially
might be used for
pharmaceutical reasons.
So we published a
study two years ago
in which we showed that--
again, in a pre-clinical study--
in animals that infusion
of these antibodies
can be remarkably effective.
You can see in animals that
have high viral loads we
can suppress virus to
undetectable levels
within seven days
for a period of time.
And in animals that start
off with low viral loads then
we fully suppress
the virus, and that
appears to be sustained
over time for over a year.
Monoclonal antibody
infusions can also
deplete virally infected cells.
So this is essentially one
measure of the viral reservoir.
And you can see with antibody
infusion it doesn't reduce this
to zero, but it certainly
reduces it substantially
compared with
uninfected animals.
So I'll conclude
briefly, and then
happy to take more
general questions.
The HIV epidemic is, I
think, unquestionably
one of the most important
biomedical challenges
of our time, both
locally in the US
and even more importantly
globally in the world.
Molecular science and
molecular-based thinking
of the pathogen and
the immune response
has revolutionized the approach
to both vaccine and drug
development.
And certainly novel HIV
vaccine and cure strategies
are going to be tested
in clinical trials
over the next few years.
I should emphasize that
these are aspirational goals,
and there is no HIV
vaccine, and there's no HIV
cure that's around the corner.
I can assure you that
neither one of these
is going to be a licensed
product in the next few years.
But by harnessing modern
immunology and virology,
we think that we have an
unprecedented opportunity
to impact not only
the HIV epidemic,
but this way of
molecular thinking
will also likely be very
effective to develop
strategies against other
infectious diseases
as well as cancers.
So I'll stop there, happy to
take more discussion questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]